more high-level diplomatic visits to
kiev on saturday uk prime minister boris
johnson and austria's chancellor carl
nehamer became the latest western
leaders to visit the ukrainian president
a day after vladimir zelinsky welcomed
european commission president ursula
wonderland and the blog's foreign policy
chief joseph warrell
johnson one of the most vocal critics of
russia's invasion of ukraine reiterated
his support for the country
and we will give
you the support that you need economic
support but also of course the defensive
military support in which i'm proud to
say that the uk
helped to
to lead the way
he pledged to send new armored vehicles
anti-aircraft anti-tank missiles and
perhaps most significantly anti-ship
missile systems
those could threaten russia's large
naval presence in the black sea
as embassies and political figures begin
to return to kiev the work to
reconstruct is destroyed neighborhoods
is ramping up
among them is the city of europe
once home to 60 000 people the city was
a front line in the battle between
russian and ukrainian forces
heavily guarded on a visit to the area
the austrian chancellor told me he found
the destruction difficult to take in
the torture of the people in the ukraine
with all the war crimes now
fierce fighting continued here for over
a month
this bridge became a focal point as
people fled the bombardment
the ukrainian army sacrificed this
bridge in order to hold the address of
russian forces as they tried to encircle
the capital as a result the city of
european has been cut off from cave
since the early days of the war now that
the russian forces left the region a
force are underway to reconnect the two
cities with a temporary bridge
russian forces have withdrawn from the
area foundations are being relayed and
connections remade
as the suburbs are linked again to the
capital so too he reinforces its link to
the world
resource al jazeera european